♪ ♪
>> Greg: HERE'S A THEORY: IN
MOST CONTESTS, THE TEAM HAVING
MORE FUN WINS AND THE TEAM THAT
LOSES ITS SENSE OF HUMOR LOSES,
PERIOD.
FRIDAY, PRESIDENT TRUMP POSTED A
MEME PREDICTING HE WOULD BE
PRESIDENT FOREVER AND EVER.
♪ ♪
>> Greg: YEAH, THAT'S
NORMAL PEOPLE, I.E. PEOPLE NOT
IN THE MEDIA, SAW THIS AS
LIGHTHEARTED TROLLING MOCKING
THE TRIGGERED TRUMP CRITICS,
LIKE THIS FELLA HERE.
>> IF HE LOSES, TRUMP, HE WON'T
GO.
I'VE BEEN SAYING THAT SINCE
BEFORE HE GOT ELECTED.
>> Greg: AND HE WAS A COMEDIAN
WANTS.
IT IS SO OBVIOUS IT HURTS BUT
STILL THE MEDIA REPORTS TRUMP'S
JOKES WAS DIRE WARNINGS, A
HEADLINE SCREAMS "TRUMP POSTS
INSEIN TWITTER VIDEO THREATENING
TO BE PRESIDENT FOR ETERNITY."
THREATENING.
WHAT MORON WRITES THIS?
I AM AWAITING THEIR EXPOSE ON
WHY THE CHICKEN REALLY CROSSED
THE ROAD OR DOES TIME FLY IF YOU
THROW A CLOCK THROUGH THE AIR?
I BET THAT GETS THREE
PINOCCHIOS.
HOW DO THESE PEOPLE GET SO, TO
USE THE MEDICAL TERM, STUPID?
THE MEDIA, ONCE OPERATING UNDER
THE GUISE OF JOURNALISM, ARE NOW
HALL MONITORS.
THEIR JOBS REDUCED TO SCREAMING
LIQUID SOMEONE'S HEAD ON TV!
IT'S A JOKE, BUT NOT US.
THEIR WORKPLACE ATTIRE IS
SWEATPANTS AN OPEN BATHROOM.
THAT IS TODAY'S MEDIA REPORTING
ON YOU AS YOU MAKE THEM THE
BUTT OF THE JOKE.
>> YOU HAVE JOKED ABOUT A THIRD
TERM.
>> I ONLY JOKE.
I JOKE AND I SAY...
>> YOU WILL ACCEPT THE RESULTS.
WHATEVER HAPPENS IN 2020.
YOU LOSE, YOU WILL BE LIKE,
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO LIKE IT BUT
YOU WALK OUT.
RECENTLY I SAID WATCH.
WE'LL DRIVE THE MEDIA CRAZY.
LET'S GO FOR -- SOME OF THE
MEDIA SAID HE'S GOING TO DO IT!
>> Greg: THE TROLLS REPORTING
ON HOW THEY GOT TROLLED.
IT'S TOO EASY AND ALMOST UNFAIR.
TWO, THREE, OR FOUR TERMS OF
THIS.
DO THEY DELIBERATELY SEE JOKES
AS THE REAL THING OR IT REALLY
IS A DISORDER?
IT'S BECOMING ONE?
>> Dana: OBVIOUSLY THAT WAS
FUNNY.
ALSO HE IS 73.
OBVIOUSLY NOT HAPPENING.
OBVIOUSLY YOU CAN'T HAVE MORE
THAN TWO TERMS.
IT TAKES A CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT.
IF YOU TALK ABOUT ABOLISHING THE
ELECTORAL COLLEGE, ALL OF A
SUDDEN, THAT'S ACTUALLY REAL.
THAT'S NOT A JOKE.
>> Greg: GOOD POINT.
>> Jesse: I LIKE WATCHING THE
DEMOCRATS CHASE THEIR OWN TAIL.
THEY ARE HUMORLESS.
IT IS SO STUPID.
IT'S LIKE WHAT YOU SAID IN THE
BEGINNING, IF TRUMP TWEETS
SOMETHING THAT HE'S NEVER GOING
TO LEAVE, THEN THEY SAY HE'S NOT
GOING TO LEAVE AND THEN THEY
ASKED AND HE SAYS I'M JOKING AND
THEN THEY STORY SAYING THE
PRESIDENT MIGHT NOT BE JOKING.
WHEN IN FACT IT IS HILLARY AND
THE LEFT TO HASN'T ACCEPTED THE
LAST RESULTS OF THE ELECTION.
THEY CALLED HIM A LEGITIMATE
RUSSIAN HACKER FOR TWO YEARS.
THEN YOU HAVE ALL THE HOLDOVERS
LIKE YATES AND McCABE AND
COMEY TRYING TO UNDERMINE HIM
FROM WITHIN.
THEY ARE TRYING TO GIVE THE
DEMOCRATS A SHOT OF ADRENALINE
SAYING THAT YOU NEED TO BEAT
TRUMP BY A LARGER MARGIN.
YOU HAVE TO BEAT HIM HANDILY IN
THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE.
THIS GUY IS A FELON.
HE'S A CHEATER, WILL INCLUDE
HER.
IF IT'S REALLY CLOSE COME HE'S
GOING TO SAY THERE'S FRAUD.
HE'S GOING TO SAY YOU CHEATED
WHEN HE IS GOING TO STAY IN
OFFICE I THINK THAT'S THE
STRATEGY.
>> Greg: WHAT IS THE AMENDMENT
THAT LIMITS YOUR TERMS?
>> Juan: YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT
ARTICLE TO AN ARTICLE TWO
ESTABLISHES THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH
AND SAYS IT'S TWO TERMS.
>> Greg: HIS NEXT THING WOULD
BE WE SHOULD REPEAL IT.
>> Juan: THE THING ABOUT IT,
ON THE ONE HAND, I SAID THIS
BEFORE.
AT THE END OF 2016, PEOPLE ASKED
WHAT HAPPENS IF HE LOSES HE SAYS
MAYBE, MAYBE NOT ALL EXCEPT THE
RESULTS.
I DON'T KNOW IF HE WAS JOKING
THERE BUT THAT'S WHAT HE SAID.
THEN HE SAYS TO CHUCK TODD IN
THE SAME INTERVIEW, HE SAYS YOU
KNOW, I WON THE POPULAR VOTE AND
CHUCK'S IS WHAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT?
HE SAYS JUDICIAL WATCH HAD A
SUIT IN CALIFORNIA.
THAT SUIT WAS ABOUT PEOPLE WHO
WERE -- SHOULD HAVE BEEN TAKEN
ON THE REGISTRATION ROLLS.
NO EVIDENCE OF FRAUDULENT
VOTING.
THE QUESTION IS WHY ARE WE
HAVING THIS SEGMENT?
[LAUGHTER]
YOU KNOW WHY WE'RE DOING IT --
>> Greg: IT'S FUN!
>> Lisa: YOU JUST PROVED
GREG'S POINTS.
THE LEFT CANNOT HAVE FUN.
>> Juan: HE SAYS THINGS THAT
MAKE YOU WONDER, DOES HE HAVE
AUTHORITARIAN INSTINCTS?
>> COME ON!
>> Lisa: HOW CAN YOU NOT CRACK
UP?
I LOVE THE FACT THAT HE'S DOING
MORE THESE MAINSTREAM INTERVIEWS
BECAUSE IT'S HILARIOUS.
THE SCENE WITH STEPHANOPOULOS IN
THE CAR AND COLLUSION MADE ME
LAUGH OUT LOUD.
YOU BENEFIT BY NOT OVERREACTING
TO IT BECAUSE HE WOULD BE LESS
INCLINED TO WANT TO DO IT.
IT'S NOT JUST HILLARY CLINTON
THAT CAN'T ACCEPT THE RESULTS OF
THE ELECTION FOR 2016.
STACEY ABRAM SAYING SHE STILL
GOVERNOR OF GEORGIA.
SHE LOST.
YOU HAVE PEOPLE LIKE JOE BIDEN
PETE BUTTIGIEG, DEMOCRATS THAT
NO BETTER SAYING SOMEHOW SHE
WOULD'VE BEEN THE GOVERNOR OF
GEORGIA DESPITE THE FACT THAT
THE 2010 MIDTERM ELECTIONS IN
GEORGIA WERE NEAR PRESIDENTIAL
LEVELS AND TURN OUT.
NO ONE WAS SUPPRESSED.
THERE WAS A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
PEOPLE THAT TURNED OUT.
SHE JUST LOST.
THEY DIDN'T VOTE FOR HER.
>> Juan: BRIAN KEMP, WHO IS
NOW THE GOVERNOR, WAS THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
>> Lisa: STACEY ABRAMS IS NOT
GOVERNOR.
>> Juan: MY POINT IS THE
PRESIDENT IS A POWERFUL MAN.
WE SHOULD NOT BE SITTING HERE
HAVING TO DEBATE, IS HE JOKING?
>> Greg: IT'S FUN!
WE ARE NOT DEBATING IT!
WE'RE NOT DEBATING HE'S JOKING
BECAUSE WE KNOW HE'S JOKING.
>> Juan: WAS HE JOKING IN
2016?
>> Jesse: FLORIDA.
MAYBE GORE --
CHUCK TODD SHOULD BE ASKING A
DEMOCRAT, WILL YOU ACCEPT THE
RESULTS OF THE 2020 ELECTION?
>> Juan: SHE SAYS SHE DOESN'T
CONSIDER HIM A LEGITIMATE
GOVERNOR.
I THINK AL GORE CONCEDED.
HILLARY CLINTON CONCEDED.